OK, this is one of those things that you probably have never heard, and then as soon as somebody tells you, you're like, right, of course. You know how murder figures into so much of American pop culture? On crime shows, and thrillers, and video games and all kinds of stuff. Well, if you knew somebody who actually got murdered, it turns out you might not be into that stuff so much.
好吧，这可能是你从未听说过的事情，但一旦有人告诉你，你会觉得，对，理所当然。你知道谋杀在多少美国流行文化中占据了重要地位吗？在犯罪剧、惊悚片、电子游戏和各种各样的东西里。嗯，如果你认识的人真的被谋杀了，结果你会发现你可能没那么喜欢那些东西了。
I can't watch Law & Order . Not going to watch Law & Order or play Clue, or go to a murder mystery dinner theater.
我没法看《法律与秩序》。我不会看《法律与秩序》，也不会玩《妙探寻凶》，更不会去参加什么谋杀悬疑晚宴剧场。
Rachel Howard's dad was killed when she was 10. And as an adult she's met a lot of people whose family members were killed. Though she says that some of them love shows like CSI and Murder She Wrote , any kind of murder show, officially, organizations like the group Parents of Murdered Children, take a stand against murder as entertainment.
蕾切尔·霍华德（Rachel Howard）的父亲在她10岁时被杀。成年后，她认识了许多家人被杀的人。虽然她说其中有些人很喜欢《CSI》和《女作家与谋杀案》这类节目，也就是任何形式的谋杀秀，但“被谋杀者父母”之类的组织在正式立场上是反对将谋杀娱乐化的。
You know, at the Parents of Murdered Children Conference, they have certain presentations really down to give you a little punch in the gut. And one of them is that they have a whole one on this murder mystery dinners. And the way that they always do it is they say, let's just pretend that you were going to have a rape mystery dinner and you were going to show up and the rule of the game was going to be that someone's been raped, and we're all going to find the rapist. That wouldn't go over. Nobody would do it. Everybody would feel that that was deeply distasteful.
你知道，在“被谋杀者父母”会议上，他们有一些演讲真的会给你一种重击感。其中之一就是关于谋杀悬疑晚宴的。他们总是这样说，假设我们要举办一场强奸悬疑晚宴，如果你去了，游戏规则是某人被强奸了，我们要一起找出强奸犯。这肯定行不通。没人会参加。每个人都会觉得这极其令人反感。
Yeah, and creepy.
是的，而且令人毛骨悚然。
Yeah, creepy. Why would you want to put yourself in that role?
是的，毛骨悚然。你为什么要把自己置于那种角色中呢？
At these conferences for Parents of Murdered Children she says, everybody has a different way of dealing with their loss. Some meet with psychologists, some with crime investigators, some with psychics. But among the families who have a murder that is unsolved, it's common for them to be on a mission to find the killers and get justice. And this is where Rachel is different. A few years ago she wrote a memoir about her family and her dad's murder. The murder was never solved. The book is called The Lost Night , and she was invited to talk about it on a radio show called The Victim's Voice . And the woman who hosts this show, her daughter had been killed, and she was one of those parents who had made it her crusade to track down the killer at any cost.
在这些“被谋杀者父母”的会议上，她说每个人都有不同的方式来处理他们的失去。有些人咨询心理学家，有些人找犯罪调查员，有些人找灵媒。但在那些谋杀案悬而未决的家庭中，他们通常都有一个寻找凶手并伸张正义的使命。而这就是蕾切尔与众不同的地方。几年前，她写了一本关于她家庭和父亲被谋杀的回忆录。谋杀案从未破获。这本书叫《迷失之夜》（The Lost Night），她被邀请到一个叫《受害者之声》（The Victim's Voice）的广播节目中谈论它。节目的女主持人，她的女儿也被杀了，她是那种把追踪凶手当作毕生事业的父母之一。
And then she was telling me the whole story about her daughter's murder and how it had been for her to never give up hope. And I have to have you on my show because it'll get the word out there. You never know what's going to come up. Who knows something. Maybe a reward will come through and I have lots of contacts in the local detectives office. And if you want me to talk to someone about your dad's case.
然后她给我讲了她女儿被谋杀的整个故事，以及她如何从未放弃希望。她说，我必须让你上我的节目，因为这样能传播出去。你永远不知道会发生什么。谁知道什么线索呢。也许悬赏会有结果，我在当地侦探办公室有很多联系人。如果你想让我和某人谈谈你父亲的案子。
And so we had this very awkward conversation. It was quite a long phone call and at every turn I was kind of saying, I'm not really interested in doing that. I don't really want to do that. I talked to the detectives and if something comes up, great. I'll be happy to know about it. But you know, this isn't really what I'm about. And she just seemed baffled.
于是我们进行了非常尴尬的交谈。那是一次很长的通话，每当她提到这个，我就说，我对做那个并不真正感兴趣。我真的不想那样做。我和侦探谈过了，如果有什么线索出现，那很好。我会很高兴知道的。但你知道，这并不是我想要的东西。而她似乎感到很困惑。
I tried to say that I had reached a point where it didn't really matter to me anymore, looking for who killed him. And that what I was doing now, he would rather see me not thinking about it every day and just moving on.
我试图说，我已经到了一个地步，寻找杀害他的人对我来说不再重要了。我现在所做的，他会更希望看到我不要每天都在想这件事，而是继续生活下去。
Rachel did have years where she felt she should be trying to figure out who killed her dad. That if she didn't let it take over her life she was being selfish, it meant she didn't love him enough. And in writing her book she started to work the case. She talked to the police, tracked down leads, made freedom of information requests for documents, tried to convince detectives to release the case file to her. And after poking around like that for a while she asked a crime reporter to look at what she had. And he suggested that she give up.
蕾切尔确实有几年时间觉得她应该努力找出是谁杀了她父亲。如果她不让这件事占据她的生活，她就是自私的，意味着她不够爱他。在写书的过程中，她开始着手处理这个案子。她联系了警察，追踪线索，根据信息自由法申请调阅文件，试图说服侦探把案卷交给她。在那样折腾了一段时间后，她请一位犯罪记者看看她手头的资料。他建议她放弃。
I remember sitting in the living room that day and having that conversation and feeling liberated.
我记得那天坐在客厅里进行那次谈话，感到一种解脱。
Why liberated?
为什么解脱？
Because this guy was telling me, look, I've looked at a lot of these cases and it doesn't sound like you have a whole lot here. And my first reaction was, good. I don't have to do this anymore. That's it. This guy just told me it's hopeless. Great. I'm free. I've done everything possible.
因为这家伙告诉我，看，我看了很多这样的案子，听起来你手里并没有什么实质性的东西。我的第一反应是，太好了。我不用再做这些了。就是这样。这家伙刚刚告诉我这毫无希望。太棒了。我自由了。我已经尽了一切可能。
And do you worry about how heartless that might sound?
那你担心这听起来会很冷血吗？
I mean, why does it sound heartless, though? Because it has nothing to do with how much I love my father. You know, why should that sound heartless? If you want to talk me about my father, I love him. I'll tell you all kinds of things about him. But why should it sound heartless to not have to keep looking for who killed him?
我的意思是，为什么这听起来冷血呢？因为它和我有多爱我的父亲毫无关系。你知道，为什么这听起来会冷血？如果你想和我谈谈我父亲，我很爱他。我会告诉你关于他的一切。但为什么不去继续寻找杀害他的人听起来就冷血呢？
It took her years to get to this point, where she felt so resolved about all this. In the Atlantic Monthly years ago, a writer named Eric Schlosser wrote, "Americans are fascinated by murder and murderers, but not by the families of people who are killed. One might expect that the families of murder victims would be showered with sympathy and support, embraced by their communities. But in reality, they're far more likely to feel isolated, fearful, and ashamed, overwhelmed by grief and guilt."
她花了多年时间才走到这一步，对这一切感到如此释怀。多年前在《大西洋月刊》上，一位名叫埃里克·施洛瑟（Eric Schlosser）的作家写道：“美国人对谋杀和谋杀犯着迷，却对受害者的家属不感兴趣。人们可能期望谋杀受害者的家庭会受到同情和支持，被社区所接纳。但现实中，他们更有可能感到孤立、恐惧和羞耻，被悲伤和内疚所淹没。”
Rachel says that she first read that when she was in college and she felt for the first time that there were other people like her, going through what she went through. That this wasn't like losing a parent any other way.
蕾切尔说她大学时第一次读到这段话，她第一次感到还有其他像她一样的人，经历着她所经历的。这不像失去父母的其他方式。
You know, everyone loses parents. You know, someone tells you, oh, my father died five years ago. Oh, I'm so sorry. That must have been very difficult. But you know that that's what we all have to go through so that person will work through it. It's not that way with murder. There's no guarantee that that person's going to work through it. They could be ruined by it forever.
你知道，每个人都会失去父母。你知道，有人告诉你，哦，我父亲五年前去世了。哦，我很遗憾。那一定很困难。但你知道那是我们所有人都要经历的，所以那个人会走出来。谋杀不是那样的。不能保证那个人能走出来。他们可能会因此永远被毁掉。
This brings us to today's radio show, people doing their damnedest not to get ruined forever by a murder in the family. From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today, How to Rest in Peace. Our show today in two acts. In act one, a son who knows that there's something wrong with him, something he has to fix when it comes to his mother's murder, and his feelings about it. In act two, a different son immerses himself in the facts of his mother's death, the cold, hard reality of it, starting long before she actually dies. Stay with us.
这把我们带到了今天的广播节目，人们正拼命努力不因家庭谋杀案而永远被毁掉。来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的主题是“如何安息”。今天的节目分为两幕。第一幕，一个儿子知道自己出了问题，关于母亲的被谋杀以及他的感受，他必须解决这些问题。第二幕，另一个儿子沉浸在母亲死亡的事实中，那冷酷、坚硬的现实，从她真正去世前很久就开始了。请留下来。
Act one. Well, we begin with this story in which a man tries to solve his problems using, among other things, videotape. Our reporter for this story is Brett Martin.
第一幕。嗯，我们从这个故事开始，在这个故事里，一个男人试图通过录像带等手段解决他的问题。我们这个故事的记者是布雷特·马丁（Brett Martin）。
One day in March of 2005, a documentary film crew showed up at the house of a woman named Sumter Adolf in Westchester County, New York.
2005年3月的一天，一个纪录片摄制组出现在纽约州威彻斯特县一位叫萨姆特·阿道夫（Sumter Adolf）的女士家门口。
Well, should we-- I don't know. Should we sit down and talk? What's best in this situation?
嗯，我们要——我不知道。我们应该坐下来谈谈吗？这种情况下什么才是最好的？
You're the director.
你是导演。
Well, we really wanted to talk to you about sort of your experiences in the house. I don't know.
嗯，我们真的很想和你谈谈你在房子里的经历。我不知道。
Mrs. Adolf had lived in the house for 21 years. It's an ordinary enough suburban home at the end of a long driveway with grey aluminum siding, patches of woods on either side, and an open field out back. She and her family love the house, but at some point they began noticing strange occurrences. They'd hear moaning and sighing. Sometimes the dishwasher would start by itself.
阿道夫太太在这栋房子里住了21年。这是一栋相当普通的郊区住宅，尽头是一条长长的车道，有灰色的铝制壁板，两边是成片的树林，后面是一片开阔的田野。她和她的家人很喜欢这栋房子，但在某个时候，他们开始注意到一些奇怪的事情。他们会听到呻吟和叹息声。有时洗碗机会自己启动。
I wouldn't even say I was cognizant of things until my daughter-- I'm going to say five or six years ago-- woke up screaming in the night. Mommy, Mommy, come, come, come. There's someone in my room. There's someone in my room. Turn on the light, there's somebody in my room. And she was under the covers terrified. I mean I've never--
甚至可以说，直到我的女儿——我想是五六年前——在夜里尖叫着醒来之前，我都没有意识到这些事情。妈妈，妈妈，快来，快来，快来。我房间里有人。我房间里有人。开灯，我房间里有人。她躲在被子里惊恐万分。我的意思是，我从来没有——
And she was 11 or 12?
她那时候11或12岁？
She must have been.
应该是吧。
On the couch, sitting across from Mrs. Adolf in her living room is 35 year old Jason Minter, the director of this documentary. Next to Jason is his younger sister, Maggie.
坐在客厅里与阿道夫太太相对的是这部纪录片的导演，35岁的杰森·明特（Jason Minter）。在杰森旁边的是他年幼的妹妹玛姬（Maggie）。
27 years ago, Jason and Maggie's mother was murdered while visiting the house, along with another mom, the woman who then lived here. Jason and Maggie, then age six and three, were listening in the next room.
27年前，杰森和玛姬的母亲在参观这栋房子时被谋杀了，还有另一位妈妈，也就是当时住在这里的那位女士。当时6岁和3岁的杰森和玛姬，在隔壁房间里听着。
I didn't really start to relate it all until we spoke.
直到我们交谈之前，我并没有真正开始将这一切联系起来。
Yeah, I mean.
是啊，我的意思是。
But a friend told me to bring a candle from church home. That a friend of his had had somebody living in their house and they burned a candle and said, go to the light. You know, it's OK. And so, as I do these things, I say, I am a mother and I understand your frustration, your anguish of leaving your kids. So it's OK. And I would try to reassure whichever mom is here. I know, I feel the same way. I'm sorry.
但一位朋友告诉我要从教堂带一根蜡烛回家。说他的一个朋友曾有某人住在他们家里，他们烧了一根蜡烛说，走向光明。你知道，没事的。所以，当我做这些事情时，我说，我是一位母亲，我理解你作为母亲离开孩子后的挫败感和痛苦。所以没事的。我会试图安抚当时在这里的任何一位母亲。我知道，我有同样的感受。我很抱歉。
Eventually, Jason and Maggie venture upstairs to the room where the murders took place.
最终，杰森和玛姬冒险上楼，来到谋杀发生的那个房间。
I don't remember this half of the house.
我不记得这半边房子了。
I remember this. I remember going up those stairs, of course.
我记得这个。当然，我记得走上楼梯。
The last time they were here, the room was a dark-paneled boys room, but now it's clearly the room of a teen girl. A border of lavender flowers runs around the walls, there's a horse figurine, and a boom box. And next to the door hangs an enormous collection of prize ribbons. The room is filled with sunlight.
他们上次来这里时，那个房间还是一个深色镶板的男孩房间，但现在显然是一个少女的房间。墙上有一圈薰衣草花边，有一个马的雕像，还有一个收音机。门边挂着巨大的奖牌奖状。房间里洒满了阳光。
I remember them coming to the door and the next thing I remember is sitting up on the bed.
我记得他们来到门口，接下来记得的就是坐在床上。
You remember that?
你记得那个？
And I remember them putting the gun to your head.
而且我记得他们把枪抵在你的头上。
Yes, I remember that as well. You remember the running from the house and so on?
是的，我也记得。你还记得从房子里跑出来等等的事吗？
I remember following you to the bedroom.
我记得跟着你跑进卧室。
And you remember-- yeah. You still have those memories? Is this too difficult?
你还记得——是啊。你还有那些记忆吗？这太困难了吗？
The weird thing in this scene is that while it's Maggie who starts to cry, it's Jason who you can't take your eyes off of. He's stiff and awkward, unsure of how to stand or where to look. If he's not breaking down, it doesn't seem to be because he's bearing up manfully under the strain. It's that he seems altogether distant feeling nothing, but clearly trying to.
这一幕最奇怪的是，虽然玛姬开始哭泣，但你的目光却无法从杰森身上移开。他僵硬而尴尬，不确定该怎么站或看哪里。如果他没有崩溃，似乎并不是因为他在压力下表现得多么坚强。而是因为他显得完全疏离，感觉不到任何东西，但显然在努力去感受。
Does the house trigger things, being in the house or no?
这房子会触动什么吗，身处这栋房子里？
It's all a little weird.
这一切都有点奇怪。
We've never talked about it before, ever, even amongst ourselves. That's a whole nother-- because we grew up really not discussing this at all. You know, we didn't discuss with my family because  our family just wanted to get over it.
我们以前从来没有谈论过它，从来没有，即使在我们自己之间。那是另一回事——因为我们长大后真的根本没讨论过这个。你知道，我们没和家人讨论，因为我们的家人只是想摆脱它。
That's why you have to do this now.
这就是为什么你现在必须这样做。
I've always thought that if I could understand everything and see everything with my own eyes again, and so on, and see how things really are and look at everything that I would feel much better. I'd feel like, you know what? I've confronted it. I can put it behind me now. Is that where you're coming from too, or no?
我一直认为，如果我能理解一切，用我自己的眼睛再次看到一切，以此类推，看看事情到底是什么样子，审视一切，我就会感觉好多了。我会觉得，你知道吗？我已经面对了。我现在可以把它抛在脑后了。这就是你想要的吗，还是不是？
Well, I don't know that I feel like I need to confront it as much as you do.
嗯，我不知道我是否觉得我需要像你那样去面对它。
I had no idea whether I would break down when I walked into that bedroom or I'd feel nothing, and I didn't feel a lot. That's for sure.
我不知道当我走进那个卧室时我会不会崩溃，或者我会什么感觉都没有，但我确实没感觉太多。那倒是真的。
It's two years after the footage of Maggie and Jason's trip to the house was shot and we're in the apartment Jason shares with his wife in Inwood, at the very top of Manhattan.
距离拍摄玛姬和杰森去那栋房子的录像已经过去两年了，我们现在在杰森和他妻子在因伍德（Inwood）的公寓里，那是曼哈顿的最顶端。
It seems like my sister has a much better handle on how to sort of deal with this than I do, or she seems to be dealing with it in a more-- what's the word? In a more natural way, I guess, than I have dealt with it. I think that's a better--
似乎我妹妹比我更有能力处理这种事情，或者说她处理的方式比我更……用什么词好呢？比我处理的方式更自然。我想这样说比较好——
What does that mean?
那意味着什么？
My sister seemed to in a way, cry on cue. I mean she seemed to react where she presumably should react when she did. She broke down and I did not.
我妹妹似乎在某种程度上可以按需哭泣。我的意思是，她在预期的反应时刻表现出了反应。她崩溃了，但我没有。
Did you ever cry?
你哭过吗？
Over my mother's death, or just in general?
为你母亲的死，还是仅仅一般来说？
Yeah over your mother's death.
是的，为你母亲的死。
No, I don't I ever have. I can't recall ever. No.
不，我不记得我曾经哭过。我不记得有。没有。
This has bothered Jason for almost 30 years, that he never had the emotions he should have had. That he never really mourned his mother's death. That's why he revisited the house and why he's filming the documentary. Making the film has become a quest in which he's resolved to revisit and catalog every aspect of the day she died.
这件事困扰了杰森近30年，他从来没有过他应该有的情绪。他从来没有真正为他母亲的去世而哀悼。这就是他重回那栋房子并拍摄这部纪录片的原因。制作这部电影已经成为一种探索，他决心重温并梳理她去世那天的一切细节。
Surely something, some detail, or person, or location, when looked at head on, even relived, will trigger the feelings he craves. The logic of this approach becomes clear when you realize that, for many years, he revisited nothing about the murder. All he knew was what he remembered from that day. And let's start there. A warning: this gets kind of violent.
肯定有些东西，某个细节、某个人或某个地点，当被正面审视，甚至被重温时，会触发他渴望的情感。这种方法的逻辑当你意识到他多年来从未重温过关于谋杀的任何事情时就变得清晰了。他所知道的只是他从那天起记得的事情。让我们从那里开始。警告：这有点暴力。
Back in 1977, the Minters were friends with another family in the neighborhood with kids the same age, a boy who was six and a girl who was three. On that afternoon, March 2, Jason had the boy over to play while Maggie went to the neighbors. It was getting late, time for the friend to go home, and for Jason's mom to pick up Maggie.
回到1977年，明特一家和邻居的另一家人是朋友，孩子年龄相仿，一个6岁的男孩和一个3岁的女孩。那天下午，3月2日，杰森让那个男孩过来玩，玛姬去了邻居家。天快黑了，是时候让朋友回家，以及杰森的妈妈去接玛姬了。
So we got in the car and we drove up to the house and there was a blue van sitting in the driveway. I think I remember my mother asking the boy if there was an electrician or plumber maybe at the house. It looked like sort of a utility vehicle. My mother and the boy walked into the house and I sat in the car alone until a guy came outside and I just remember a guy wearing like a ski cap and started letting the air out of the tires while I was sitting in the car and I thought, well, is he-- maybe this van is related to some sort of auto mechanic or something and he's doing something to the car. And then he snatched my mother's purse out of the front seat and said, hey, kid, your mother wants you. And I followed him up into the house. We walked in and the house looked like a hurricane had hit the inside of it. It was completely destroyed.
所以我们上了车，开车去那栋房子，车道上停着一辆蓝色货车。我想我记得我母亲问那个男孩是不是有电工或水管工在家里。它看起来像是某种多用途车。我母亲和那个男孩走进了房子，我独自坐在车里，直到一个人出来，我只记得一个戴着滑雪帽的人，在我坐在车里的时候开始给轮胎放气，我想，嗯，他是——也许这辆货车和某种汽车修理工有关，或者他在对车做些什么。然后他从前座抢走了我母亲的钱包，说，嘿，孩子，你母亲找你。我跟着他走进房子。我们走进去，房子里面看起来像被飓风袭击过一样。完全被毁了。
The guy took me up the stairs and into a room where my mother and the other woman were sitting on a bed. My sister was sitting on a bed with her friend and my friend was also sitting there as well. The little girls were crying and the boy was trying to calm them down. I remember one of the guys calling my mother or the other woman a bitch. I was silent for a while and then I couldn't hold it in any longer. I just became more and more alarmed. I started to talk. What's going on? What is this? Who are you? And one of the guys took a, I guess it was a 22 caliber pistol and cocked the trigger and pressed the gun against my nose and said, "Shut the [BLEEP] up." And then I was quiet.
那个人带我上楼走进一个房间，我母亲和另一个女人坐在床上。我妹妹和她的朋友坐在床上，我的朋友也坐在那里。小女孩们在哭，男孩试图安抚她们。我记得其中一个人称呼我母亲或另一个女人为婊子。我沉默了一会儿，然后我再也控制不住了。我开始变得越来越惊慌。我开始说话。发生了什么？这是什么？你们是谁？其中一个人拿着，我想那是一把22口径的手枪，扣动扳机，把枪抵在我的鼻子上说，“闭上你的[哔]嘴。”然后我就安静了。
And then I remember the men looking in, brushing a shower curtain aside with a pistol, like looking into the tub. And they went through an adjoining bathroom into another bedroom with the women. They closed the door and the next thing I knew-- I thought I heard only four shots. Of course, now I realize I was 14 or something. But we heard these shots and then we heard the van screech away and then knew that these guys were gone. Went into the room and saw-- I went in first. I told everyone to stay there and saw the two women who were both-- well, my mother was lying face down. I guess the other one was on her side. And there was blood I recall, but not a lot. It was clear to me that they had been shot in the head, or at least my mother had. But it wasn't clear that she was dead. I remember the other boy coming in, lifting his mother's arm up, and it just dropping. And that's when I ran from the house.
然后我记得那几个人向里看，用手枪推开浴帘，就像在查看浴缸。他们穿过相连的浴室，带着那两个女人走进另一个卧室。他们关上了门，接下来我所知道的就是——我以为我只听到了四声枪响。当然，现在我意识到我当时才14岁还是怎么着。但我们听到了这些枪声，然后我们听到货车尖叫着开走，就知道这些人走了。我走进房间，看到——我是第一个进去的。我告诉每个人待在那里，然后看到那两个女人，她们都——嗯，我母亲脸朝下躺着。我想另一个侧着身子。我记得有血，但不多。我很清楚她们是被枪击了头部，或者至少我母亲是。但不清楚她是否死了。我记得另一个男孩进来，抬起他母亲的手臂，然后它就垂了下来。就在那时，我从房子里跑了出来。
Jason ran through the woods to the closest neighbor's house. At first, the family there didn't believe him. Then the other kids came running up behind and the police were called. Two days later, three men would be arrested in what would turn out to be a burglary gone terribly wrong.
杰森穿过树林跑到最近的邻居家。起初，那家人不相信他。然后其他孩子跟在后面跑过来，警察被叫来了。两天后，三名男子被捕，这起案件最终演变成一起糟糕透顶的入室盗窃案。
The night of the murders, Jason and his father slept together in a room at the neighbor's while police cars came and went next door. In the night, he listened while his father wept. Nobody ever actually told Jason that his mother was dead. In fact, when he'd asked the cop at the scene of the crime if she was OK, the cop said, sure. Jason wasn't taken to the burial. Finally, he got the idea that she would never be coming back. And that's pretty much where his information stopped for the next dozen years.
谋杀案发生的当晚，杰森和父亲睡在邻居家的一个房间里，警察的车在隔壁进进出出。夜里，他听着父亲哭泣。从来没有人真正告诉杰森他母亲死了。事实上，当他在犯罪现场问警察她是否没事时，警察说，当然。杰森没被带去葬礼。最终，他意识到她再也不会回来了。这基本上就是他接下来的十几年里所知的一切信息。
I should say at the outset that in the years following the murder, Jason was sent to the parade of therapists you'd expect. His father seems to have tried to do everything he could do, given the fact that he was going through a devastating trauma of his own. But none of it gave Jason what he was looking for, a way to grieve his mother's death. So when he was 19, he took a train to White Plains where the killers had been tried. At the courthouse he'd photocopied the police reports and then he sat and devoured them on the way back to Grand Central. For the first time, he learned the names of his mother's killers.
我应该一开始就说，在谋杀后的几年里，杰森被送去看了你所能预料到的一系列治疗师。他父亲似乎尽了他所能做的一切，考虑到他自己也在经历毁灭性的创伤。但没有一项给他带来了他想要的东西——一种为母亲哀悼的方式。所以他19岁时，坐火车去了凶手受审的白原市（White Plains）。在法院，他复印了警察报告，然后在回中央车站的路上狼吞虎咽地读完了它们。第一次，他知道了母亲凶手的名字。
He learned that only two of the men had participated in the murders, while the third man, James Walls, who Jason had seen letting the air out of his mother's tires, had waited in the van, not knowing what was going on. He also learned more disturbing details. Both his mother and the other woman had been raped before being killed. His mother had been shot three times. The first was to the head and likely killed her instantly. The other woman, not as lucky, had been shot some 11 times.
他得知只有其中两人参与了谋杀，而第三个人，也就是杰森在给轮胎放气时看到的那个叫詹姆斯·沃尔斯（James Walls）的男人，当时一直在货车里等，不知道发生了什么。他还得知了更多令人不安的细节。他的母亲和另一个女人在被杀前都遭到了强奸。他的母亲被开了三枪。第一枪打中头部，很可能当场死亡。另一个女人没那么幸运，被开了大约11枪。
While all of this was horrifying for Jason, it was also, oddly satisfying. For the first time, he felt like he was getting a grasp on the murder. And this is where the idea of the documentary came to him. Under the pretense of shooting the film, he could accomplish what time hadn't and what therapy hadn't. He would continue to work his way through the case bit by bit, like a brass rubbing, until finally the picture was complete and he could move on.
虽然这一切对杰森来说都是可怕的，但奇怪的是也让人感到满足。第一次，他感觉自己抓住了这起谋杀案。这就是纪录片想法产生的地方。借拍摄电影为名，他可以完成时间和治疗都没能完成的事。他会继续一点一点地钻研这个案子，就像做拓片一样，直到画面最终完整，他就能继续生活下去。
All right. I don't know. I don't see any semblance of any-- well, here's a number.
好的。我不知道。我没看到任何……嗯，这是一个数字。
We went to a district attorney's office, which one I'm not allowed to say. I wasn't supposed to do this at all, but they were sort of cutting me a break. But anyway, I went to a district attorney's office and looked through, I think there were six or nine banker's boxes full of evidence. Everything from the police reports to crime scene photos, to autopsy photos, and so on. And methodically, I went through them one by one.
我们去了地区检察官办公室，哪个办公室我不被允许说。我本不应该做这个的，但他们算是给了我一点宽限。总之，我去了地区检察官办公室，翻看了，我想有六到九个银行家用来装文件的箱子，里面全是证据。从警察报告到犯罪现场照片，再到尸检照片等等。我一丝不苟地把它们逐一过了一遍。
Oh, this is Shirley Abraham's testimony. Very interesting.
噢，这是雪莉·亚伯拉罕（Shirley Abraham）的证词。非常有趣。
In the boxes were many letters. Letters from one of the murderers, Willie Profit, nicknamed "Scrap," to his girlfriend at the time. And there was a letter from James Walls, the guy who had stayed in the van to the same woman, whose name was Shirley. In its, Walls pleads with Shirley to corroborate his story that he didn't commit any of the violence that day. He also narrates the murders from his perspective. Another warning: here it gets more graphic.
箱子里有很多信。其中一个凶手威利·普罗菲特（Willie Profit），绰号“废料”（Scrap），写给他当时女友的信。还有一封是詹姆斯·沃尔斯，那个在货车里等的家伙，写给同一个女人的信，她的名字叫雪莉。在信里，沃尔斯恳求雪莉证实他的说法，即他那天没犯下任何暴力行为。他还从他的视角叙述了谋杀过程。再次警告：这里的内容变得更加血腥。
A few seconds, I heard a woman's voice say, it must be the furniture people or something. I heard Scraps say, hold it, bitch. And I saw another little boy in the lady's car. I then told the boy his mother wanted him. He got out of the car and went inside. I then went and picked the lady's pocketbook off the front seat and put it in the van.
几秒钟后，我听到一个女人的声音说，那一定是家具工人什么的。我听到“废料”说，闭嘴，婊子。我看到那个女人的车里还有另一个小男孩。我随后告诉那个男孩他母亲找他。他下了车走进屋里。然后我去从前座拿起那女人的钱包放进货车。
I waited in the van about 10 minutes, then got out. I walked in the front of van thinking that Scrap and Sammy were tying the two ladies up. I'm still in front of the van and that's when I hear the shots. Then I was about to jump in the van and drive away. As I was about to do so, Scrap and Sammy came running out of the house, hopped in the van, Scrap said to me he's going to drive, so he did. He was laughing and acting like a madman, and so was Sammy. I asked them, did you guys really shoot those ladies? And they both said, yes. I said to them, why? I think Scraps said, because the lady saw their faces. And then Sammy said to me, D, I don't know that little black had a long black [BLEEP]. And then Scraps said, boy, I [BLEEP] out of that bitch, D. And I said, what? And Sammy said, yeah, D. He [BLEEP] out of her. And then Sammy says, he [BLEEP] the fat bitch.
我在货车里等了大约10分钟，然后下车。我走到货车前面，以为“废料”和萨米（Sammy）在绑那两个女士。我还站在货车前面，这时我听到枪声。我正要跳上货车开走时，“废料”和萨米从房子里跑出来，跳上货车，废料告诉我他来开车，于是他开了。他当时在笑，表现得像个疯子，萨米也一样。我问他们，你们真的开枪杀了那些女士吗？他们两个都说，是。我问他们，为什么？我想废料说，因为那女人看见了他们的脸。然后萨米对我说，D，我不知道那个小黑人有个长黑[哔]。然后废料说，兄弟，我[哔]了那个婊子，D。我说，什么？萨米说，是的，D。他[哔]了她。然后萨米说，他[哔]了那个肥婊子。
And then I said to myself, these guys are made man-- madmen. And Shirley, keep in mind that these are the facts and the truth, and the only words of truth. Because remember, I was at the scene of the crime. Be cool and keep your head up, D.D. Walls.
然后我对自己说，这些人是疯子。雪莉，记住这是事实和真相，也是唯一的真相。因为记住，我在犯罪现场。放轻松，抬头挺胸，D.D.沃尔斯。
That's quite a letter. I feel like I should have a round of applause or something for reading that.
真是封好信。我觉得我读完这些应该得到掌声什么的。
Jason continues going through boxes, avoiding the folder of crime scene photos until his friend who's behind the camera prods him along.
杰森继续翻看箱子，避开了犯罪现场照片文件夹，直到摄像机后面的朋友催促他。
Look at the pictures.
看照片。
You, what are you, Oprah? Going to make me look at something. I mean, look, I'm getting to horrible stuff now. Photo exhibits.
你，你是奥普拉吗？要让我看这些。我的意思是，看，我现在要看可怕的东西了。照片展。
Oh, Jesus. Well, I guess we had to get to it sometime.
噢，天哪。好吧，我想我们迟早得看。
This, I believe, is my mother and this is what I saw that day. And I think I mentioned that I thought she was still alive. I mean, as you can see the wounds are from a small caliber gun. To a kid that didn't look like a really big deal. I don't find it all that disturbing. No, I really don't.
这就是我相信的我母亲，这就是我那天看到的。我想我提到过我以为她还活着。我的意思是，你可以看到伤口是小口径枪造成的。对一个孩子来说，那看起来并没有什么大不了的。我并不觉得它有多么令人不安。不，真的没有。
I mean, first of all I'm not seeing my mother's face in these pictures. She's lying face down. I don't know. I'm not getting that-- Jesus, what is this? What the hell is this stuff now? They turn the bodies over?
我的意思是，首先我没在这些照片里看到我母亲的脸。她是脸朝下躺着的。我不知道。我没有那种——天哪，这到底是什么？现在这些又是什么鬼东西？他们把尸体翻过来了？
So how did Jason get here? How did he stay numb for so long that he needs to stare at pictures of his mother's corpse to try to provoke a reaction? Not only was his mother's death never discussed while he was growing up, neither was her life.
那么杰森是怎么走到这一步的呢？他怎么会麻木了这么久，以至于他需要盯着母亲尸体的照片试图引发反应？不仅他母亲的死在他成长过程中从未被讨论，她的生前也从未被提及。
Soon after the murders, Jason's father remarried, to a woman who, for motives that seem to be a mix of well intentioned and kind of crazy, set about erasing all the physical evidence that Jason's mother had ever existed. Jason doesn't even know how many letters and photos and other personal items his new stepmother threw out. But he knows that all the gifts his mother had given him disappeared. His father divorced his second wife and married a third.
谋杀发生后不久，杰森的父亲再婚了，娶了一个动机似乎既是好心又有点疯狂的女人，她着手抹除所有关于邦妮·明特（Bonnie Minter）曾经存在过的物理证据。杰森甚至不知道他的继母扔掉了多少母亲的信件、照片和其他私人物品。但他知道他母亲送给他的所有礼物都消失了。他父亲与第二任妻子离婚，又娶了第三任。
Jason developed a severe case of separation anxiety. The fear that he was going to lose his father too. He also decided that it was up to him to see that nothing like the crime ever happened again.
杰森患上了严重的分离焦虑症。担心他也会失去父亲。他还决定，确保类似罪行不再发生是他的责任。
Like sort of security obsession where I built locks for doors and windows in our house, and drilled holes in things, and built weapons, and did all sorts of things to protect the home, protect the family. I built weapons and I hid them all over the property and all over the house.
就像某种安全偏执，我为家里的门窗制作锁，在东西上钻孔，制造武器，做了各种各样的事情来保护家，保护家人。我制造武器，把它们藏在房子和地点的各个角落。
What kind of weapons did you build?
你制造了什么样的武器？
I had all sorts of things. I had bats with nails sticking out of them, to makeshift morning stars, to swords, to spears, to clubs. I had an arsenal of BB gun and pellet guns.
我什么都有。我有插着钉子的球棒，自制的流星锤，剑，矛，棍棒。我有一个BB枪和气枪的军火库。
And these were spread out around your house?
这些都散落在你的房子周围？
Well, yes. Yes, they were. When I got a little older I set up a really primitive closed circuit TV in my room. I had a card table and an old black and white television sitting on it. Then I had probably one of the first affordable consumer video cameras to ever come out, it was sitting in the hallway just pointing at the stairs. And I would just sit there staring at the stairs with a bunch of BB guns on the table.
嗯，是的。是的。当我大一点的时候，我在房间里装了一个非常原始的闭路电视。我有一张卡牌桌和一台旧黑白电视机放在上面。然后我可能有史以来第一台负担得起的消费级摄像机，它就放在走廊里，对着楼梯。我会坐在那里盯着楼梯，桌子上放着一堆BB枪。
You would spend hours doing that?
你会花几个小时做那个？
I would spend hours staring at it, waiting for somebody to just come-- basically-- make my day.
我会花几个小时盯着它，等待某人出现——基本上——让我得偿所愿。
At one point, I was building-- I had seen Ben or Willard on television and I thought that I could raise rats and train them to sort of protect me and the family, and sort of do my bidding. So I had this plan to go to the pet store and buy some rats. And I started building a pen down in one of the old stables and my father caught me hauling a big door down. He said, what are you doing? And I said, I'm going to set up a pen to raise rats. And he just looked at me and said, no you're not.
有一次，我正在制造——我在电视上看到本（Ben）或威拉德（Willard），我想我可以养一些老鼠，训练它们来保护我和家人，并按照我的意愿行事。所以我计划去宠物店买些老鼠。我开始在旧马厩里建一个围栏，我父亲抓住我在拖一扇大门。他说，你在做什么？我说，我要搭个窝来养老鼠。他只是看着我说，你才不会。
I mean, I'm curious that you say-- it sounds like your sense of your dad's response to all this was that he was annoyed by it.
我的意思是，我很奇怪你说——听起来你觉得你父亲对此的反应是他很烦。
He was annoyed by it. And you know, I don't remember the specific incident. I mean, I think I was putting maybe a new lock on the basement door or something and drilling holes. And he came home from work and caught me doing this. I said, well, how can you not be afraid? How can you not be nervous? And he said, because lightning doesn't strike the same place twice. And that annoyed me because I just didn't buy that at all.
他很烦。你知道，我不记得具体的事件了。我的意思是，我想我可能在给地下室的门装新锁或者什么，在钻孔。他下班回家正好抓到我。我说，你怎么能不害怕？你怎么能不紧张？他说，因为闪电不会击中同一个地方两次。这让我很恼火，因为我根本不相信那套说法。
For all the confusion and trauma of his youth, Jason did manage to graduate from high school, go to film school, get married, and basically take care of himself. In fact, it's impossible to tell Jason's story without at least mentioning what he does for a living.
尽管少年时代充满了混乱和创伤，杰森还是设法从高中毕业，上了电影学校，结婚，基本上照顾好了自己。事实上，如果不提到杰森以什么为生，就不可能讲完他的故事。
For the past nine years or so, he's worked for the TV show The Sopranos . First as a location manager, essentially driving through suburban neighborhoods looking for houses where he could stage murders. And then as an associate producer and assistant to the show's creator, David Chase. I'm not the first person to have drawn a connection between his childhood experiences and the fact that he wound up spending almost a decade helping to recreate graphic, often random and senseless violence on screen. I'm also not the first person to have Jason shut me down. Jason says it has nothing to do with his childhood. He didn't create the series. He didn't write the series. Sometimes a good job is just a good job.
在过去大约九年里，他为电视节目《黑道家族》（The Sopranos）工作。起初担任外景经理，基本上就是开车穿过郊区寻找可以布置谋杀场景的房子。后来担任联合制片人，是大卫·蔡斯（David Chase）的助理。我不是第一个把他的童年经历和他最终花了近十年时间帮助在屏幕上重现图形化、往往是随机且毫无意义的暴力行为联系起来的人。我也不是第一个被杰森拒之门外的人。杰森说这和他的童年毫无关系。他没创造这个系列。他没写这个系列。有时候，一份好工作就只是一份好工作。
So on and off for years, Jason was doing one of the few things you can do to get over a trauma. He returned to the details of what happened. He immersed himself in them, filming all sorts of people and locations. And when it failed to deliver the emotional catharsis he was looking for, he became gripped by a different goal. He doesn't just want to revisit his mother's murder, he also wants to re-solve it. Never mind that the police solved it years ago and that the three men involved were all serving sentences of 25 years to life. Jason's totally serious about this and spent probably a third of our interview on the subject.
所以多年来，杰森断断续续地在做少数几件能帮你克服创伤的事情之一。他回到了事情发生的细节中。他沉浸在其中，拍摄各种人和地点。而当它没能带来他所追求的情感宣泄时，他被另一个目标抓住了。他不仅想重温母亲的谋杀，他还想重新破案。别管警察多年前就已经破案，且涉及的三个人都在服25年至终身的监禁。杰森对这件事完全认真，并在我们的采访中花了大约三分之一的时间在讨论这个话题。
For a long time, he's had the suspicion that maybe the murders weren't entirely random. That the killers didn't just happen upon that house by accident, but were sent there to kill a particular person. He even has a theory about who and why, a theory I can't actually repeat on the radio because it's probably libelous.
很长一段时间以来，他一直怀疑谋杀案也许并不完全是随机的。凶手并不是偶然碰巧遇到那栋房子，而是被派去杀害某个人。他甚至有一个关于是谁以及为什么要这么做的理论，一个我不能在广播中重复的理论，因为那可能是诽谤。
He talks about interviewing up to 30 more people. From assistant DAs to distant relatives of the killers, almost all of them to help make his case. And when the Department of Corrections agreed to set up a meeting in the medium security wing of Attica with James Walls, the guy who had stayed in the van, Jason had visions of finding some kind of new clue to support his theory.
他谈到要采访多达30个人。从助理检察官到凶手的远房亲戚，几乎所有人都是为了帮他支持他的理论。当惩教署同意在阿提卡监狱（Attica）的中等安全区安排一次与詹姆斯·沃尔斯的会面时，杰森幻想着能找到某种新的线索来支持他的理论。
Would you be Mr. Walls? Mr. Walls, I'm Jason Minter. How are you?
你是沃尔斯先生吗？沃尔斯先生，我是杰森·明特。你好吗？
I'm fine.
我很好。
Last time you saw me I had hair. So did you for that matter.
上次你见到我时我还有头发。你也是。
Yes I did.
是的，我有。
For the record, yes, the last time they saw each other was the day of the murders. This joke should give you a sense of the tenor of the conversation, which is held in an empty prison cafeteria. Jason's all business.
为了记录，是的，他们上次见面是谋杀那天。这个笑话让你感受到对话的基调，对话是在一个空荡荡的监狱食堂里进行的。杰森完全是在谈正事。
Walls is a middle-aged black man with a neat moustache and oversized round wire glasses. He slides back and forth between expressing regret for his involvement in the crime and self pity over the unfortunate coincidence-- almost 30 years ago-- of running into the murderers as they were on their way to what they said would be a simple breaking and entering.
沃尔斯是一个中年黑人，留着整齐的胡子，戴着一副过大的圆形金属框眼镜。他在表达对参与犯罪的后悔和为近30年前偶然遇到那些去进行简单入室盗窃的凶手而自怜之间徘徊。
Meanwhile, Jason has his gumshoe hat on and hammers away at the point he's most interested in. Did the other two men know where they were going, or did they choose a random home?
与此同时，杰森戴着他的侦探帽，反复敲击他最感兴趣的问题。那两个人知道他们要去哪里，还是他们选了一个随机的房子？
What did they say? Do you remember specifically? Did they say they were going on a B&E, or was it something else? Did somebody tell them about--
他们说了什么？你记得具体吗？他们是说去进行B&E（入室盗窃），还是别的？有人告诉他们关于——
No, they was conversing about a breaking and entering, but they didn't know where they was going as far as what I understood.
不，他们在谈论入室盗窃，但据我了解，他们不知道要去哪里。
So there's no chance of them knowing, there was no chance of them targeting any of these houses, do you think? They couldn't have known about this, any of these houses?
所以他们不可能知道，他们不可能针对任何这些房子，你认为呢？他们不可能知道这些房子中的任何一个？
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
You don't think so?
你不这么认为？
No. Because the way they was acting inside the van when they were-- they was talking more or less like pick and choose.
不。因为他们在货车里的表现——他们谈论的或多或少像是随便挑的。
So you really don't think they knew where they were going?
所以你真的不认为他们知道自己要去哪？
No. Because like I was saying. after they made an approach to one house and the woman came to the door and the dog was barking, they sort of like backed up. Because when they saw the big dog, like I said, they sort of backed up and jumped right back into the van and took off. And they was talking [BLEEP] about, yeah, man, you see that big ass [BLEEP] dog, man. I ain't [BLEEP] going in. It was one of those things where, let's go over here.
不。因为就像我说的。在他们靠近一栋房子，那个女人来到门口，狗在叫之后，他们算是退缩了。因为当他们看到那条大狗，就像我说的，他们算是退缩了，跳回货车开走了。他们谈论[哔]说，是啊，伙计，你看到那条大狗了吗，伙计。我不[哔]去。那是那种情况之一，我们去别的地方吧。
None of this could have come as a surprise to Jason because everyone tells him his theory is almost certainly false. Including the cops who investigated the case who Jason interviewed. When pressed, even Jason admits there's not much evidence to back him up. Still, it's easy to understand the allure of the idea that the crimes weren't just a random incident. Imagine going through life not just knowing, but really knowing that your life can implode in the worst possible way at any moment. Imagine internalizing the notion that every little decision, like driving over to the neighbor's house to drop off a friend, could put you in the path of disaster.
这些对杰森来说都不应该是个惊喜，因为每个人都告诉他，他的理论几乎肯定是错误的。包括那些调查此案并被杰森采访过的警察。当被追问时，即使是杰森也承认几乎没什么证据支持他。尽管如此，很容易理解这种观念的吸引力：如果这些罪行不仅仅是一个随机事件。想象一下，不仅知道，而且真正明白你的生活随时可能在最糟糕的方式下崩溃。想象一下内化了这种观念，即每一个小决定，比如开车去邻居家送一个朋友，都可能让你走上灾难的道路。
If that sense of a random universe were gone, it might allow Jason to stand down his defenses. And not just metaphorically. Jason's apartment features a level of security that's excessive even by New York standards. Three dead bolts and a heavy burglar bar are on the door. Jason says he'd own a gun if New York state didn't make it such a pain to get a license. Instead, scattered about are a collection of swords, including a samurai number that Jason keeps by the bed. There's also a sai, then an ax that Jason insists are antiques rather than weapons, but look like they'd probably do in a pinch.
如果那种随机宇宙的感觉消失了，杰森也许就能放下防备。不仅仅是隐喻层面。杰森的公寓安全程度即使以纽约标准来看也过于极端。门上有三道锁和一根沉重的防盗杆。杰森说如果纽约州没让申请执照变得那么麻烦，他会拥有一把枪。相反，到处散落着一堆剑，包括杰森放在床边的一把武士刀。还有一把拐子，然后是一把杰森坚持说是古董而不是武器的斧头，但看起来在关键时刻也能凑合。
Nothing Jason has done has gotten him any closer to getting rid of those weapons, let alone moving past his mother's death. And lately, he's slowed down his investigation of the murder night. He has permission from the prison system to go see the two killers themselves, but he hasn't been able to bring himself to pay a visit.
杰森所做的一切并没有让他更接近于摆脱那些武器，更不用说走出他母亲去世的阴影了。最近，他减缓了对谋杀之夜的调查。他有监狱系统的许可去见那两个凶手本人，但他一直无法让自己去探访。
Are you at all afraid that you're going to some day know everything and not feel any better?
你是否担心有一天你会知道一切，却一点也没觉得好受？
Yeah, certainly. I wouldn't be any worse off than I am now for that matter. I mean I'm certainly a functional adult. Well, a functional immature adult.
是啊，当然。反正也不会比现在更糟。我的意思是，我肯定是一个功能正常的成年人。好吧，一个功能正常的未成熟成年人。
You seem quite functional. I mean, as far as I can tell. As far as certainly on the scale of external problems you could have. You are married. You've held a job for a long time. You're starting a business. You have a nice house, two cats. You are capable of social interaction. I mean, these are all things-- so what is your problem?
你看起来很正常。我的意思是，据我所知。至少在你可以拥有的外部问题范围内。你结婚了。你有份工作很久了。你正在创业。你有一个漂亮的房子，两只猫。你有社交能力。我的意思是，这些都是——那你的问题是什么？
Well, are you asking what I hope to accomplish by--
好吧，你是想问我希望通过——达到什么目的？
Well what is missing? What is the drive? Is this for you or is it for your mother?
什么缺失了？动力是什么？这是为你自己，还是为你母亲？
My hope is that I'm able to stop or to cease to obsess over that day. I hope to not think about the murder 26 times a day. Maybe once a day or once every two days. To stop sort of obsessing about it.
我的希望是我能停止或不再执着于那天。我希望每天不要想26次谋杀案。也许一天一次或两天一次。停止那种执念。
And here, three hours into our interview, an interview that began with him declaring that if he just knew everything about the murder night he could move on, we get to this--
在这里，在采访进行了三个小时后，一个开始时他宣称如果他知道关于谋杀之夜的一切就能继续生活的采访，我们得到了这个——
You know, I looked at crime scene photos, I went back into that room. I talked to one of the guys and where did it get me? I just feel like I haven't accomplished the task yet.
你知道，我看了犯罪现场照片，我回到了那个房间。我和其中一个人谈过，结果呢？我只是觉得我还没完成任务。
Has it occurred to you that maybe it's not that you haven't done enough, but that the exercise is flawed?
你有没有想过，也许不是你做得不够，而是这个练习本身就有缺陷？
That has occurred to me. Absolutely. Now I feel like I wonder whether I should just, really just intensely try to focus on my mother and forget-- not forget about the crime, obviously. But try to stay away from that as much as possible, mentally and to just not make the rest of the film.
我想过。绝对想过。现在我感到，我想知道我是否应该真的，只是极度地尝试专注于我母亲，并忘记——显然不是忘记犯罪。但尽可能远离那些，在心理上，并且不要拍电影剩下的部分。
About a year ago, Jason found a box of old cookbooks that belonged to his mother in his father's garage. Somehow they'd been overlooked by his first stepmother when she was purging the house of Bonnie Minter's things.
大约一年前，杰森在他父亲的车库里发现了一箱属于他母亲的旧食谱。不知何故，当他第一任继母清理邦妮·明特的东西时，这些被忽略了。
You know, yeah, I found old recipes that were stuffed into these pages that weren't looked at that she stuffed in there 30 years ago. That's when it occurred to me that you've never really thought of your mother as a real person. She's just been this event or this horrible thing that happened to you. Not that she was a horrible thing, but she was a victim of this horrible thing that, in some ways, has defined my whole life.
你知道，是啊，我发现了一些塞在这些书页里的旧食谱，那是30年前她塞进去的，没人看过。就在那时我意识到，你从未真正把母亲看作一个真实的人。她只是这个事件或者是发生在身上的可怕事情。并不是说她是一个可怕的东西，而是她是这个可怕事件的受害者，在某种程度上，它定义了我的一生。
Yeah, that wall is OK. Most of it's going to come down. It's just a big garage here. But you can see the potential.
是的，那堵墙没问题。大部分都要拆掉。这只是一个大车库。但你可以看到潜力。
When The Sopranos ended, Jason decided to get out of television and open a restaurant. He leased a corner storefront not far from his apartment and negotiated a good deal to buy the tables, chairs, and service ware of Vesuvius, the Soprano's fictional Italian joint.
《黑道家族》结束后，杰森决定退出电视行业，开一家餐厅。他在离公寓不远的地方租了一个拐角的门面，并以优惠的价格买下了《黑道家族》中那家虚构的意大利餐馆Vesuvius的桌椅和餐具。
One clear memory Jason has of his mother is of her in the kitchen. He remembers long strands of fresh pasta slung between chairs throughout the house. And finding the cookbooks made him think that cooking could be a way to connect with her memory.
杰森对自己母亲的一个清晰记忆是她在厨房里。他记得家里椅子之间挂着的长长的鲜面条。找到这些食谱让他想到烹饪可能是联系她记忆的一种方式。
There will be a big, wine, beer bar over here. Sort of an open kitchen.
这边会有一个大的酒和啤酒吧。一种开放式厨房。
Right now the space is raw and empty, but it's a beautiful spot looking out on a green stretch of trees and park. Jason and his wife have put a huge Halloween display in one window for the neighborhood kids. It would be glib to say that the restaurant is the opposite of the documentary. That one looks back and the other forward. One focuses on what's lost, the other on building something new. That one's about death and the other life. It's just too simple to be true. But standing there in the space, listening to Jason describe his vision for a homey neighborhood hangout, seeing people stop by to ask when he'll finally open, it does seem a little true.
现在这个空间还是原始且空旷的，但这是一个可以看到一片绿树和公园的美丽地点。杰森和他的妻子在窗户上放了一个巨大的万圣节展示给邻居的孩子们看。说餐厅是纪录片的对立面会显得太轻率了。说一个回望，另一个向前。一个关注失去的，另一个关注建立新的。一个关于死亡，另一个关于生命。这太简单了，不可能完全真实。但站在这里，听着杰森描述他对一个家庭式邻里聚集地的憧憬，看着人们停下来问他什么时候开业，它看起来确实有点真实。
As he's locking up, a boy and his father come walking out of the park. The kid runs up to the door, tries to push his way in. Not quite yet, Jason says hopefully. Soon.
当他锁上门时，一个男孩和他的父亲从公园走出来。孩子跑向门口，试图挤进去。还没到时候，杰森充满希望地说。快了。
Brett Martin, he's a correspondent for GQ magazine.
布雷特·马丁，他是《GQ》杂志的记者。
In the two years since we first broadcast this story, Jason has opened his restaurant, Indian Road Cafe. It's thriving. His mom's murderer agreed to be interviewed for Jason's movie, but with the restaurant so busy, the film's on hold for now.
在我们首次播出这个故事后的两年里，杰森开了他的餐厅，Indian Road Cafe。生意兴隆。他妈妈的凶手同意接受杰森电影的采访，但餐厅太忙了，电影暂时搁置。
[MUSIC- "IT'S ALL RIGHT TO CRY" BY MOUFETTE]
[音乐-《哭泣没关系》]
Coming up, your mom calls you up and says, I want to rehearse my own suicide. And you're a good kid, you want your mom to be happy, and you get in your car and you go help her. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将到来，你妈妈打电话给你说，我想排练我自己的自杀。你是个好孩子，你希望妈妈快乐，你开车去帮她。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "How to Rest in Peace."
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，并为你带来各种各样关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“如何安息”。
Well, so far today, we've heard from people who have had a really hard time getting over the violent death of a parent. Now in act two, we turn to somebody who's actually kind of at peace with his mother's death, which when you hear how she died, is kind of amazing.
嗯，今天到目前为止，我们已经听到了那些在克服父母暴力死亡方面遇到很大困难的人的故事。现在在第二幕，我们转向一个实际上对母亲去世感到平静的人，当你听到她是怎么死的时候，这真是令人惊叹。
Her plan was to take the whole bottle of pills sitting in her bed with a plastic bag ready and a scarf ready to wrap around her neck to seal the bag. And that she would take the pills, put the plastic bag on, put the scarf around, and lie down. And that's what she did.
她的计划是把一整瓶药片拿在床上，准备好塑料袋，准备好一条围巾裹在脖子上封住袋子。然后她会吃掉药片，戴上塑料袋，围上围巾，躺下。她就是这么做的。
We'll call this guy Edward. And when his mother killed herself at 79, she wasn't depressed, she wasn't sick with some terrible illness. No, she was lively, funny, social, able to take care of herself. But she planned for her own death for decades ever since she saw what happened to her mom when her mom got old. Her mother suffered from dementia, became confused and incoherent. Edward's mom had a hard time even visiting her mom during those years.
我们称这个人爱德华。当他79岁的母亲自杀时，她没有抑郁，没有患什么可怕的疾病。不，她很活泼、风趣、善于社交，能照顾自己。但她为自己的死亡策划了几十年，自从她看到母亲变老时发生的事情后。她的母亲患有痴呆症，变得困惑和语无伦次。爱德华的母亲在那些年里连探望母亲都很困难。
Also, she hated doctors. Hated them. Hated hospitals too.
而且，她讨厌医生。讨厌他们。也讨厌医院。
It was a strong, gut feeling on her part that this was terrible. She couldn't stand the thought of seeing people in hospitals with tubes coming out of them. And she was determined never to be in that environment if she could possibly help it. And she and my father-- but really at her initiation-- promised each other that they would help each other. That they would not let each other suffer in old age. And they bought the book, Final Exit , by Derek Humphrey, which talked about this. They were counting on each other.
她有一种强烈的直觉，认为那太可怕了。她无法忍受看到人们在医院里插着管子。她决心只要能做到，就绝不进入那种环境。她和我父亲——但主要是她发起的——向对方承诺，他们会互相帮助。他们不会让对方在晚年遭受痛苦。他们买了德里克·汉弗莱（Derek Humphrey）写的《最终离别》（Final Exit）这本书，谈到了这一点。他们指望对方。
And at some point she gets you involved in this, right?
在某个时候，她让你参与进来了，对吧？
She got me most involved when my father died. What she asked me to do was to basically, to play the part that my father would have done for her. But he was dead. And I felt it was an obligation to do this for her.
她在父亲去世时让我参与最多。她要求我做的是，基本上，扮演我父亲本来会为她扮演的角色。但他死了。我觉得我有义务为她这样做。
Did she say it so flatly as, I want you to do what your father would have done?
她的话说得那么直白吗，比如，“我想让你做你父亲本来会做的事”？
I forget how she phrased it. She was really asking me not to interfere, not to oppose, to support her in this. She didn't want me to help her. She was very concerned about something happening to me. She didn't want me to be in trouble. She didn't even want me to be embarrassed. She said, the ambulance is going to come and the police will come and the neighbors will see. It'll be bad for your reputation. How can I do this?
我忘了她怎么说的了。她确实是要求我不要干预，不要反对，要在这件事上支持她。她不想让我帮她。她非常担心我出什么事。她不想让我惹上麻烦。她甚至不想让我尴尬。她说，救护车会来，警察会来，邻居会看到。这对你的名声不好。我怎么能做这种事？
So I was in the rather odd position of having to reassure her that she could do this without embarrassing me. So I was in this double situation of not wanting to encourage her, but also wanting to comfort her so that she doesn't feel anxious about the consequences for me or anybody else.
所以我处于一个相当尴尬的境地，不得不向她保证，她可以在不让我尴尬的情况下做到这一点。所以我处于这种双重境地，不想鼓励她，但也想安慰她，这样她就不会对我和其他人的后果感到焦虑。
But that's the thing that I was wondering, is it seems like you're in a very delicate position because you don't want to be encouraging her, I assume, to kill herself.
但这就是我好奇的地方，因为你似乎处于一个非常微妙的位置，因为我不认为你会鼓励她自杀。
That's correct. I didn't want to encourage her, but I didn't want to refuse to discuss it with her, to help her emotionally go through the process of talking about it and dealing with the preparation for it.
没错。我不想鼓励她，但我不想拒绝与她讨论这个问题，也不想拒绝在情感上帮助她完成谈论和处理准备过程。
It's interesting. I think a lot of people are so uncomfortable talking about death with someone else. Was it hard for you?
很有趣。我想很多人对和别人谈论死亡感到非常不舒服。这对你来说很难吗？
It wasn't that hard, and I got used to it. I had a lot of preparation. This was nothing new. And she was very focused on this end for well over 20 years. It was just an established fact. This is what she wanted. This is the way I could love her. This is what she really asked me for. She didn't ask me for anything. This is what she asked me for.
没那么难，我习惯了。我做了很多准备。这并不新鲜。她为这个结局专注了20多年。这是一个既定的事实。这是她想要的。这是我能爱她的方式。这是她真正向我要求的。她没向我要过什么东西。这是她向我要求的。
She used to say that she did not want to live to be very old. She said 80. That's far enough. Why do I have to live past 80? She would go into this stuff.
她过去常说她不想活到很老。她说80岁。够了。为什么我一定要活过80岁？她会陷入这些东西里。
Why live past 80?
为什么活过80岁？
Right. I don't want to get so old. Why do people want to live so long? What's the point?
对。我不想变得那么老。为什么人们想活那么久？有什么意义？
Did she have the experience of observing herself getting more forgetful and feeling more confused and she knew that she was experiencing dementia, the early stages of it, and she remembered her mom?
她是否有过观察自己变得越来越健忘并感到困惑的经历，她知道自己正在经历痴呆症的早期阶段，而且她还记得她母亲的情况？
I observed for the last 10 years, a slow deterioration. She had been always a big cook and taking cooking lessons, and Chinese, and all sorts of things. And at the very end, about a month before she died, she had asked my wife to come down and she said she couldn't make a cup of coffee. She just couldn't make a decent cup of coffee. She was really frustrated she had to go out for coffee. And so she asked my wife to come down and show her what was going wrong. And my wife spent about an hour trying to explain the process of using a French press, which is what she was using. Which is about as simple a way to make coffee as you can have.
我观察了最后10年，一种缓慢的恶化。她一直是个大厨，上烹饪课，学中文等等。在最后，大约在她去世前一个月，她让我妻子过来，她说她做不出一杯咖啡。她只是做不出一杯像样的咖啡。她非常沮丧，不得不出去买咖啡。所以我妻子过来，给她演示哪里出了问题。我妻子花了一个小时试图解释使用法压壶的过程，那就是她正在使用的。那是你能有的最简单的咖啡制作方式之一。
Right. You take the grounds, you put it in, you pour the water on top. You wait, and then you push the thing down.
对。你放咖啡粉，加水。等一下，然后把东西压下去。
Exactly. It was a real struggle for her to get that. And I think that's the kind of thing that she did all the time. These kinds of things could all of a sudden become an incredible burden to her.
正是。这对她来说是个真正的挣扎。我认为这就是她一直做的那种事情。这些事情突然之间都成了她难以置信的负担。
Now one of the things I wanted to ask you about that I know you went through is that your mom would rehearse. Like she would run through scenarios and drag you into this?
现在我想问你的一件事我知道你经历过，就是你妈妈会排练。她会走一遍场景，然后把你拉进去？
Well, she did a test. She knew that she had to get some sleeping pills. So she basically went to two different doctors and lied and said that she couldn't sleep and needed it. She took a couple of these and I was there. She wanted to see what would happen. And she took two of these and she was out in a matter of a couple of a couple of minutes. She started rehearsing because she was afraid that she wouldn't be able to do it. Or she wouldn't remember to do it. Or she wouldn't remember what to do. So she would ask me to come down and watch her while she did this.
嗯，她做了一个测试。她知道她必须弄到一些安眠药。所以她基本上去了两个不同的医生那里，撒谎说她睡不着觉，需要这个。她拿了几片，我在场。她想看看会发生什么。她吃了两片，几分钟内就睡着了。她开始排练，因为她担心自己无法做到。或者她会忘了怎么做。或者她会忘了该做什么。所以她会让我过来，在她这样做的时候看着她。
And so what was it like?
那感觉是什么样？
It was weird. It was definitely weird.
很奇怪。绝对很奇怪。
And so, wait. So you'd be at home and she'd call you up and she'd say, like, can you come on over tonight, I want to rehearse the thing.
等一下。所以你会待在家里，她会打电话给你说，今晚能过来吗，我想排练那件事。
I want to practice.
我想练习。
Really? That's it?
真的？就是这样？
Exactly. There would be some joking about it and that kind of stuff. And she was not somber. She wasn't depressed.
完全正确。会开一些关于它的玩笑等等。她并不阴沉。她没抑郁。
And so you would like order in some Chinese and go over to your mom's house.
所以你会叫点中餐，然后去你妈妈家。
Maybe she invited me for dinner. She would make the dinner and she would invite me for dinner, and then she would do the practice.
也许她请我吃晚饭。她会做饭并请我过去吃，然后她会进行练习。
And she also wrote out a note to be prepared. She wanted to be prepared, so she wrote out a note explaining what she was doing in a more lucid moment when she could do that. And she got her things that she wanted to use. You know, the scarf, and the bag, and the note, and she actually put together the books, like the Final Exit book and I think she had some other books. She placed it all out, so that anybody coming, and the police, I had to call the police. And when they came, this was all laid out.
她还写了一张纸条作为准备。她想做好准备，所以她在更清醒的时刻写了一张纸条解释她在做什么。她拿到了她想用的东西。你知道，围巾、袋子、纸条，她实际上把书放在一起，比如《最终离别》那本书，我想她还有其他一些书。她把这一切都摆好了，所以如果有人进来，警察，我必须报警。当他们来的时候，这一切都已经摆好了。
It's interesting. It isn't just her rehearsing herself, it's almost like she was rehearsing you too, so you could go through your feelings when it would finally happen.
很有趣。这不仅仅是她在排练自己，几乎就像她也在排练你，这样你也能在事情最终发生时理顺你的感受。
I think so.
我想是这样。
Now legally, could she call you and say OK, I'm doing it today and have you know?
法律上，她能打电话给你说“好的，我今天要做”，然后让你知道吗？
Everybody knew. The family came. She did this at the end of August and over the summer her sister and brothers came, my cousins came, and friends came to pay a visit. And I was calling people and explaining that she's planning to do this and it's not going to be that long, and maybe you would like to come and visit her. And people did come. With her brother, who was the last one, she played a total game with him. He was opposed to her doing it. He thought she was depressed. And he thought that she just needed to get out. So he wanted to invite her down to New York City. They'd go into the city and do things that she used to like to do. And go to the museums and go out and so he was trying to encourage her to do that thinking that she must be depressed. And she said, sure. And they made plans for her to go down to the city the next week. And when he left she called me and said she's going to do it now.
每个人都知道。家人都来了。她在八月底做了这件事，夏天的时候她的姐妹兄弟、表兄弟姐妹和朋友都来探望了。我当时给人们打电话，解释她计划这样做，而且时间不多了，也许你想来看看她。人们确实来了。至于她的兄弟，最后一个来的，她完全是在捉弄他。他反对她这样做。他认为她抑郁了。他觉得她只是需要出去走走。所以他想请她去纽约市。他们会进城做她过去喜欢做的事。去博物馆，出去玩，所以他试图鼓励她这样做，认为她一定抑郁了。她说，当然。他们计划她下周进城。当他离开时，她给我打电话说她现在就要做了。
She said that if I don't do it now, I will not be able to do it.
她说如果我现在不做，我就再也没法做了。
Did she do it right after the brother was there because she realized that she was weakening? That she could weaken? She could just--
她在兄弟走后立即做是因为她意识到自己正在变得虚弱吗？她会虚弱？她可能只是——
I don't think so. I think she played a total game with him. She would not want to hurt his feelings while he was there. She would just play along. He's telling her these things and she would say, oh, sure. That sounds lovely. But she would know inside of herself, this isn't at all what she wants. And I think that she knew that she was really losing her ability to organize her thoughts enough to be able to carry this out.
我不这么认为。我认为她完全是在捉弄他。当他在的时候，她不想伤害他的感情。她只是顺着说。他说这些话，她会说，噢，当然。听起来很棒。但她内心知道，这根本不是她想要的。我认为她知道自己真的正在失去整理思绪的能力，以至于无法实施。
And so then you have to hang up the phone, and then you're sitting in your house and you know that she's in her house and she's doing this thing right then?
然后你不得不挂断电话，然后你坐在家里，你知道她在她家里，她正在做这件事？
No, I went down. She asked me to come down.
不，我去了。她让我过去。
Oh, she did?
噢，她让你过去？
Yeah. So I went down. And we talked about it. And she was determined to do it. And she got all her stuff ready and we said goodbye, and I left. And it was very odd, me leaving knowing what she's doing.
是啊。所以我去了。我们谈了谈。她决心要这么做。她把一切准备好，我们说了再见，我离开了。真是太奇怪了，我知道她在做什么还要离开。
Where'd you go?
你去哪了？
I just drove around. I went shopping. I went to the supermarket. I didn't know what to do. I mean I didn't sit there wringing my hands. It was somewhat surreal, the experience.
我只是开车转转。我去购物了。我去了超市。我不知道该做什么。我的意思是，我没坐在那儿绞着手。这是一种超现实的体验。
It just seems so sad that she has to be alone at that moment.
在那一刻她必须独自一人，这看起来太悲伤了。
It was terrible.
这太可怕了。
It seems like that's the moment where of all moments she would want somebody with her to hold her hand and comfort her.
看起来在那一刻，在所有时刻里，她会想要某个人陪着她，握着她的手，安慰她。
Right. That was probably the worst part of it, that she had to do it alone. Me and her other family members could not be there because we live in a society that does not respect people's desire to control the end of their life.
对。这可能是最糟糕的部分，她必须独自一人完成。我和她的其他家庭成员不能在那里，因为我们生活在一个不尊重人们控制生命终点愿望的社会中。
So you go back into the house. Was there a part of you where you thought, well, maybe she didn't do it?
所以你回到房子里。有没有一部分你想，好吧，也许她没做？
My fear was that she didn't die. That I would go in and should be still alive. She had taken this overdose of medication and somehow she was still alive and what was I going to do then? I mean the worst thing, the last thing she would want me to do is to call an ambulance and take her to the emergency room. I mean, that would be the last thing she would want. She did me a great favor by being successful.
我怕的是她没死。我进去时她还活着。她吃了过量的药物，不知怎的还活着，我该怎么办？我的意思是，最糟糕的事，她最不想让我做的事就是打救护车送她去急诊室。那将是她最不想看到的。她能成功，对我来说真是帮了大忙。
It just seems so terrible. You walk in and it seems so-- the fact that she's there with a bag over her head.
这看起来太可怕了。你走进去，看起来太——事实是她在那儿，头上套着个袋子。
Yes. It was odd. And it was an image that stays with me. I honestly didn't sit in the room for a long time. It wasn't something that I wanted to have imprinted on me any more than it had to be. And it was very emotional, obviously, to see her dead. And I sat down and I cried at that moment as I am now. Then I had to walk down to the police and tell them that she had done it and they came.
是的。这很奇怪。这是一个一直留在脑海里的形象。我诚实地说，我没有在房间里待很长时间。这不是我想比必须留下的更深印在脑子里的东西。看到她死显然非常感性。我坐下来，在那一刻哭了，就像现在一样。然后我不得不走到警察那里告诉他们她已经做了，然后他们就来了。
And they took it seriously. I told them the whole story. I told them that the relatives had all come and talked about it. Everybody knew what was going on. And they took evidence. They took the glass that she had used. And they took her note and got fingerprints and all that kind of stuff. But she had handled everything. She had done it all.
他们认真对待了。我把整个故事告诉了他们。我告诉他们亲戚都来过谈论过这件事。每个人都知道发生了什么。他们取了证据。他们取走了她用过的玻璃杯。他们拿走了她的纸条，提取了指纹之类的东西。但她处理好了一切。她一个人做完了。
Do you have a sense that your mother tamed death? That she made it less frightening for herself by going into the details and thinking it through to this degree?
你有没有觉得你母亲驯服了死亡？她通过钻研细节并深思熟虑到这种程度，让自己对死亡没那么恐惧？
I think she did. I think that would be accurate. I think that she had the normal fear of death. Fear of unknown, fear of also losing life. And I think by talking about it is the way that she convinced herself.
我想她做到了。我想那很准确。我想她有对死亡的正常恐惧。未知的恐惧，还有失去生命的恐惧。我想通过谈论它，就是她让自己信服的方式。
I've got to say it seems very rare for somebody to get to that point and to come to grips with death in such a thoughtful way.
我不得不说，一个人能达到那一点，并以如此深思熟虑的方式接受死亡，这真是太罕见了。
I think it is. You don't hear about it frequently. People who are involved in assisted suicide are usually people who have objectively certifiable problems.
我想是的。你不会经常听到。参与协助自杀的人通常是那些有客观可证明问题的人。
What's interesting talking to you about it is how at peace you are with it. How there's no ambiguity that it was the right thing.
关于它谈话很有趣的一点是你对此感到多么平静。没有任何模糊之处，这真的是正确的事情。
I think I'm expressing the determination that she had. She was her own unique person. This is what she wanted. This is the way she thought about life. My son had children just a few years after she died and she would have very much like to have seen that. But that year, I think within six months of her death, her sister was killed in an automobile accident, and I think that she would have been devastated by that. So who can say what she should have done or not done?
我想我表达的是她拥有的那种决心。她是她自己独特的人。这就是她想要的。这就是她看待生活的方式。在我母亲去世几年后我儿子有了孩子，她会非常希望能看到这一点。但那一年，我想在她去世六个月内，她的姐妹在车祸中丧生，我想她会被那件事摧毁的。所以谁能说她该做什么或不该做什么？
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, John Jeter, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Bruce Wallace and Aaron Scott. Seth Lind's our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
嗯，我们的节目今天由萨拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和我有艾利克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、约翰·杰特（John Jeter）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同制作。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。布鲁斯·华莱士（Bruce Wallace）和亚伦·斯科特（Aaron Scott）提供了制作帮助。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）运营我们的网站。杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's come up with a new scheme to solve his personnel problems. All the employees that he's unhappy with, all of us who don't do what he wants, he's lining up some replacements.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。WBEZ对我节目的管理监督来自我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他想出了一个新方案来解决他的人事问题。他不满意的所有员工，我们所有不按他要求去做的人，他都在排队寻找替换者。
And I thought that I could raise rats and train them to sort of do my bidding.
我以为我可以养些老鼠，训练它们来听从我的命令。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多关于这个美国生活的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。